15 plus 10 thank you iransko and we're
playing a 1400 um with the white pieces
so
we're gonna go one e4 as we usually do
and we're facing e4 e5
which surprisingly we have not faced
quite as much so far in the speed run
thank you king yak and we're facing a
philadelphia this is i think the first
time that we face a philidor
uh which is you know has always been a
relatively popular alternative to knight
c6
and one which uh isn't known to be
particularly dangerous but nonetheless
it's very solid and
uh it's good to know what to do against
the philidor there's a couple of
approaches that white can take in the
philidor most people are familiar with
the move d4 here that is sort of the
traditional main line but if you're an
italian player you can also start by
developing your bishop to c4 and only
later
potentially go d4 in fact i like that
approach more i like going bishop c4 in
this position
and what's flexible about this move is
that you can also potentially play pawn
d3
uh and transpose to kind of an italian
structure if that's what you prefer but
uh most probably we're going to end up
playing d4 anyway
the bishop of course belongs on c4 in
these positions
bishop b5 check here makes
not a lot of sense because yeah because
he could have just played c6
all right so black plays c6 i'm not
familiar with this move
uh but it it seems like our opponent
isn't prioritizing their development
um
so
well so in response to that it's only
natural for us to open up the center
with d4 but we can still delay that for
one move if we want we can castle here
which would be totally fine
but at this point i don't see a reason
not to play d4 i think the time has come
for us to open the center let's go d4
delayed narrow con that's right
okay b5
um this kind of play is quite common
at this level and it's nothing to be
scared of our opponent is pushing pawns
on the queen side in the meantime we've
already developed our pieces and
occupied the center so there's nothing
insane that you have to do here just
drop the bishop back to b3
yeah obviously bishop back to b3 we want
to stay on this diagonal e takes d4
now which piece should we take with well
generally speaking you want to take with
a knight in such positions taking the
queen uh could make the queen quite
vulnerable to various attacking ideas
like c5
so
i would prefer to take with a knight
here just centralizing my guess is that
he's orienting towards c5 but c5 is bad
for several reasons there it is this is
bad for several reasons one of which is
very prosaic he's trying to pose a
noah's arc trap where if the knight
moves black plays c4 and and traps the
bishop but
the first thing is that we can take the
pawn on b5 simply
and there's no more c4 but
who sees the second thing that we could
do
now i'm not talking about queen f3 i'm
talking about a direct refutation
yeah bishop d5 when there's no
development you have to look for such
moves bishop d5 cd4 bishop takes a8 and
the bishop easily evacuates and we're up
a full exchange both of these options
are great the second one wins more
material but it sacrifices some of our
lead in development the first option is
sort of the go for the kill option
uh where we you know we grab the pawn
and we preserve our leader development
but
you know in this speeder and we're
trying to play as clinically as possible
we're not trying to win any
d4 all eventually so we're going to have
an exchange and a pawn up which is a lie
which is a lot
this is a great illustration of you know
what happens when you don't develop your
pieces
luck will be on you if you develop
naturally but you miss something like
this luck is going to be on your side
right you're going to
get lucky and go lucky because the side
with more development tends to
um
tends to prevail in these tactical
skirmishes you're going to have some
resource
okay so we have won the exchange
he's likely to give us a check on a5 i
would imagine
seems like this guy likes okay queen b6
and b6 is is a is a good move defending
the pawn on d4
now what is our next order of business i
think a lot of you guys would be tempted
to play bishop d5 here and say
we need to evacuate the bishop from a8
but let's probe that question for a
second do we actually need to get the
bishop out from a no we don't the reason
that we don't is because we always have
the d5 square which is protected by the
pawn
and we can always put our bishop there
if need be but the bishop is quite safe
on hate it's almost impossible to
actually attack that bishop and so
castling is the simplest and best
approach here
bishop e7 continuing his development
now there are two approaches to
dealing with this pawn on on d4
the first approach is to maneuver this
knight either to f3 or probably even
better to b3
in order to attack the pawn once again
the second approach is to transform our
advantage and rather than go for winning
this pawn
the second approach involves training
this pawn but giving us far freer
development for our pieces
and lalia sees the move at c3
that might seem counterintuitive why are
we trading our opponent's weakness well
we're simply transforming our advantage
from a situation where we're attacking
this pawn with our pieces to a situation
where now our knight's going to get the
c3 square let me go c3 let's see how
this unfolds
this is a classic transformation of the
advantage kind of thing
what did we get in return for letting
him
trade this week pawn first of all we get
the c3 score for a night second of all
we get the e3 score for our bishop third
of all we would have gotten the c file
but knight a6
um
okay so i think he's trying to get his
knight to c7 that's that's a cool idea
uh but it's not particularly dangerous
we can play queen takes d4 if we want to
go for the queen train in fact that's
probably what i would do in a classical
game
that's probably what i would do in a
classical game is like queen
uh queen takes d4
and let's do it let's play queen takes
d4 this essentially forces the queen
tray because we are also attacking the
g7 pawn right this is basically a fork
one could think of it as a fork
okay
now i wouldn't even grab the pawn the
queen immediately we can also throw in
the intermediate move bishop c6 jack but
no need to be fancy the bishop is
perfectly safe on a in and if he goes
knight c7 then we're gonna play bishop
c6
okay
now we're obviously winning but how do
we capitalize as quickly as we can as
efficiently as we can
i think a lot of people here would be
tempted to go bishop e3 nothing wrong
with that move but we have a more
effective more straightforward way to
win the game who sees it
and this should be an instinct for you
because he's undeveloped on the king's
side we can just throw the spawn toward
e5 and it's gonna work out
because if he takes twice we go rookie
one this is a classic idea pinning the
bishop
and then winning the bishop
with our pawn f4 and this is exactly
what he falls into rookie one
f6 f4
this is a very important type of motif
that you should be aware of
and that's it
now it's over there is a resilient move
night before in this position
but i have a response prepared for that
and he's cooked
and in general anytime your opponent's
king remains on e8
or remains on e1 you should never assume
that you need to defend anything on the
e-file right because of the idea of this
pin
all right well
let's just
grab that pawn with check
no need for us to
rush our development i mean there's
nothing that he could do to us so we can
uh
take our time mop up all the pawns and
then later we can bring our knight and
our bishop into the game
and at this point and this is something
that i've noticed
a lot of people struggle actually in
positions like these to win efficiently
so
in order to win efficiently you
basically the fastest method is just to
go after the king
so bishop d5 is a very natural way of
doing that it forces the king back to fa
because if the king walks up to f6 then
of course the rook swoops into e8 and we
win more pieces
okay there we go
rookie 8 and now it's totally over
bishop
okay so bishop d7 obviously not bishop
takes jake because the rook is hanging
but rook takes g8
and we're up a million pieces okay this
force is the rook trade the rest is
pretty simple without too much
commentary we're up a rook and a piece
as i always say in these situations as
we see him resign
it's less important the individual move
you make uh what's more important is
that you're adhering to the general to
the correct general strategy thank you
jen sim for the six months
yeah i mean this was a very simple game
it was a quick loss
so the philidor
is is has a has a solid reputation it's
not a bad opening
uh but i don't recommend it to beginners
actually because it it needs to be
played very precisely
and a lot of times beginners tend to
play it or intermediate players tend to
go for it because it seems very solid
it's like okay i'll play d6 i'll defend
the pawn
and then i'll somehow i'll develop my
pieces but you can lose really quickly
in the philidor if you're not careful
yeah c6 is already weird it's a typical
move in these lines but not necessarily
here
i mean i think generally black goes
bishop e7 in these positions because if
knight f6
you're walking into a potential fried
liver type idea
okay so c6 d4 b5 bishop b3 so all of
this is already kind of dubious for
black but c5 is the decisive mistake
of course he should have gone knight f6
and urgently urgently started to develop
his pieces
uh which i still think gives black a a
pretty reasonable game i don't think
that black is in horrible shape here in
fact this could end up being favorable
for black if he completes his kingside
development
um yeah the last thing i did did get
banned
uh but c5 is just way too naive
i mean first of all it blunders the pawn
like this second of all it blunders the
exchange like this
any time your opponent is this
underdeveloped ideas that involve
winning the rooks
ideas that involve winning the rooks are
extremely prevalent
and should be considered and i've
previously shown
one of my games from when i was 1600
where i actually blundered a very
similar type of idea because i didn't
pay attention to my own development
um and i've shown that moment before on
stream my opponent didn't punish me for
it but it was a memorable moment
nonetheless
okay so this is from 2005. um
this position was reached in one of my
games um this is round two i'm playing
so many i'm out ready and i kind of very
casually go b6 in this position
i kind of automatically go b6
and i won the game quite easily c4
queenie i mean i fiancadoed my bishop
then i won a pawn i won another pawn and
i won the game
didn't think anything of it until my
coach yelled at me
what did i miss in this position
in fact white wins on the spot here
white wins on the spot
95 yeah knight e5 ends the game simply
because bishop f3 is totally unstoppable
no matter where you move the queen
bishop f3 is going to trap the rook in
the corner
if you play bishop b7 that makes matters
even worse because you're going to lose
the bishop and the rook
and if you try being cheeky that also
doesn't do anything because the king
just steps aside and you lose an entire
rook you can't even get in exchange for
it
so just be very careful about opening up
the diagonal to your rook anytime that
you're not very well developed or you
have a queen in the vicinity
just be aware of these types of ideas
that involve getting a bishop or even a
queen
uh to f3 or to e4 because sometimes you
actually can't extricate the rook
just something to file away into your
kind of your mental library
right
that was a nice game um
all right guys it's two o'clock i'm
tired i have to do winter stays and i
have to be ready on camera seven hours
from now which means that i do need to
get some rest all right thanks for
hanging out everybody have a great
start to your wednesday i'll see you
guys later
bye everybody
[Music]